- [Instructor] We're
going to do in this video
is get some practice doing division
with numbers that are
multiples of 10, 100, 1,000,
things like that.
So let's say we wanted to compute
what 2,400
divided by 30 is.
Pause this video,
and see if you can calculate it
using whatever strategy
makes sense to you.
Alright, so let's think
about this together,
and I'm gonna show you how my
brain likes to handle this.
We'll do this out on my
little digital blackboard,
but eventually you'll be
able to do things like this
in your head.
So 2,400 or 2,400 divided by 30,
that is the same thing as 2,400
over 30.
So this is just another
way of saying 2,400
divided by 30.
Now the reason why I wrote it this way
is because you can now
write each of these,
the numerator and the denominator
as the product of some number
and either 10 or 100 or 1,000.
So 2,400, that's the same
thing as 24 times 100,
and I knew that.
I was like, okay, I've got
these two zeros at the end,
so you could view this
literally as 24 hundreds,
and then 30 you can view as,
we got one zero here,
so it's three tens.
The three is in the tens place.
So three times 10.
Now what's valuable about
thinking of it this way
is you can separately
divide the 24 by the three
and then the 100 by the 10,
so this is the same thing as,
lemme do this this way,
as that times that.
And so we have 24 divided by three
times 100 divided by 10.
Now 24 divided by three,
you might already know
that is going to be eight.
Three times eight is 24.
So this is going to be equal to eight,
and what's 100 divided by 10?
Well, 100 divided by 10
is just going to be 10,
so our quotient, I guess you could say,
is going to be eight times 10,
or it's going to be equal to 80,
and we're done.
And you might notice
something interesting here.
So if I take my 24
and divide it by my three,
I'm gonna get this eight,
and then if I take two zeros
and if I take away another zero,
I'm gonna be left with
one zero right over here.
So you get 80,
but why did that thing
with the zeros work?
Because you're really
just taking 2,400 hundreds
divided by three tens.
So 100 divided by 10,
well, you're gonna lose a zero.
That's gonna be equal to 10,
which has only one zero.
Let's do another example
just to hit the point home,
and try to do this next example
the way we just did it,
maybe in your head
or maybe on a piece of paper.
So let's say we wanted to calculate 3,500,
which you could also think of as 3,500,
and we wanna divide that by,
lemme write the division symbol
a little bit nicer than that.
We wanna divide that by 700.
Pause this video and see
if you can compute that.
So as we just did,
we could view this as 3,500 over 700.
3,500 we can view as 35
times 100
over, this is going to be over.
Lemme get the right color here,
over seven times 100.
Now the one hundreds cancel out,
and we're just left with 35 over seven.
Now what's 35 divided by seven?
Well, that is going to be equal to five,
and notice, you could just say 35
divided by seven is five,
and if you're saying, "How many
zeros do I have left over?"
Well, I have two zeros here,
but since I'm dividing by
something with two zeros,
those two zeros are
going to be canceled out.
I don't want you to just memorize that.
The reason why that happens is
because those two zeros here
represent hundreds, 35 hundreds.
These two zeros represent hundreds,
so if you divide 100 by hundreds,
they're all gonna cancel out.
So you had two zeros before,
but you're dividing by
something with the two zeros,
so you don't have any
zeros after the five here.
Lemme do one more example
just to really hit that point home,
but I want you to appreciate that
it's not just some magical trick.
It just makes sense out of things
that you might already know.
So if someone, and I'm
gonna give a crazy one,
let's say we had 42 million
divided by,
let's say, 60,000.
What is that going to be?
Pause the video and see
if you can think about it
on your own.
Well, using the notions
that we just talked about,
you could say, "Alright, 42 divided by six
"is going to be seven."
And then if I, let's see,
over here I have six zeros,
so we're talking about millions,
and I'm gonna divide by
four zeros right over here,
which is 10 thousands.
So if you had six zeros,
or if you have millions with six zeros
and you divide by 10
thousands with four zeros,
six minus four is gonna be two,
so your answer's gonna
have two zeros in it.
So this is going to be equal to 700.
Now once again, not a magical trick,
the way that we got this
is that this is equal
to 42 times a million.
We got our six zeros right over there
divided by
six 10 thousands,
six times 10,000.
So our 42 divided by six,
that's where we get the seven from,
and now one way to think about it,
if we divide the numerator
and the denominator by 10,
we lose a zero.
Then we do it again.
We lose zeros.
We do it again.
We lose zeros,
and so this thing just all becomes one,
or another way to think about it,
if we divide the numerator
and the denominator by 10,000,
this becomes one.
This thing loses four zeros,
and you're left with,
42 divided by six is seven hundreds,
because we have a one
now in the denominator,
100 divided by one, so 700.